-You brought them in.
I can't believe these are
the headphones that you,
a television personality,
you are actually --
actively running with
these headphones?
[ Laughter ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
Needless to say you
had to get the attachment.
It looks like -- were these,
did these used to be a chew toy
for your old iguana?
[ Laughter ]
They're crazy.
-What's wrong with
the headphones?
-They look like --
well, first of all,
if I saw somebody
jogging by with this,
I would assume they had
started in the past.
[ Laughter and applause ]
They had run from the past.
-Everyone who sees those says,
"How did you get those vintage
headphones?"
[ Laughter ]
And I say that I got them
at Duane Reade last week,
because they're still
selling them.
-Oh, really? Is that true?
-Yes.
-Now, I will say,
I don't want totally
run down these headphones,
because I do believe --
I'm serious.
I'm going to say something true.
I don't use brand-new headphones
either.
I -- I find an old --
there's like a Sony headphone
that goes over the ear,
because normal headphones
fall out of my ear immediately,
and these stay on.
-Yes, if you've got a little
raisinette in your ear,
I don't see why
that's better than this.
Nothing -- no one
can pull these off.
[ Laughter ]
This is an air-tight operation.
-Now on your commute --
[ Cheers and applause ]
Have you had to --
I'm assuming this
is the first time anyone's
wrapped these up, yeah.
-My children are here.
Thank you so much.
-Have you had to do any errands
on your run?
Have you had to do any sweaty
errands on your commute?
-Oh, yeah, well --
now, I like to combine
a run and an errand, too.
-Yeah.
-But the problem with that
is you've got your cash
in your sports bra.
Maybe you guys don't.
[ Laughter ]
If you have another option,
please tell me afterwards,
but I keep my cash here.
And then so when you go to
pay for something
and you're, like --
[ Panting ]
[ Laughter ]
And hand them a dollar bill
that has like, wilted already --
people don't want that.
-They don't want that.
-They'd rather keep
their merchandise than --
-Even from a celeb,
they don't want it.
-They don't know.
[ Laughter ]
-I want to talk briefly
before --
You played Giuliani
a couple of weeks ago.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-I did, didn't I?
-How was that?
-Well, you know,
this was a --
that was not my idea,
I want to say.
It was the idea
of one of our best
and most wonderful writers,
Kent Sublette, I guess.
And he said the night before,
do you want to do Giuliani?
And I said..."Yeah?"
[ Laughter ]
Okay. Turns out,
it wasn't as hard as I thought,
because we have something
in common
which is that we
both go like this.
[ Laughter ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
And I've been -- Yeah.
-So it was secretly...
[ Laughter ]
Yeah, he maybe was stealing
the move from you.
-I think he was, because I've
been doing it a long time.
-I'm so happy for you that
you are going to have a break,
and you're going to do a show
on Saturday.
And then you're going to have
the summer to do other things.
Well-deserved.
I can't wait, of course,
for you to come back next year.
-Thanks.
-Kate McKinnon, everybody.